et on en parle avec stéphane drouin qui
est directeur général du conseil
québécois du commerce de détail bon je
me suis droit bonjour vous comment
est-ce que vous accueillez cette annonce
sont un peu l'impression de notre côté
qu'on avait une nouvelle couche sur les
épaules des commerçants pour leur fait
jouer à quelque sorte la route la police
l'a effectivement vous résumer très bien
les enjeux de façon globale les
commerçants comprennent là l'enjeu de
santé publique la décision du
gouvernement comme ils l'ont bien fait
depuis le début mais là de se faire
imposer l'application de la règle
surtout de se faire grandir des amendes
en cas de non application web donc qu il
concrètement lorsqu'un client va se
pointer sans masquer les commerçants
devront l'interpeller et on pourrait
même devoir appeler la police le bain ce
qu'on a compris exactement la raison des
règles compliquées entre eux du moins à
court terme
c'est qu'effectivement le ballet des
temps faisait déjà souvent un contrôle
de gestion nombre de clients et de geste
et aussi l'application de produits
nettoyants pour les meilleurs magasins
il doit y avoir un contrôle
additionnelles qui le port du masque à
l'entrée du magasin
si vous n'êtes peut-être plus difficile
c'est soin de gérer des clients qui sont
régalés distrait la mesure hélas à
savoir des serpents dangereux et ils ont
aussi que la majorité de la population
devraient s'y conformer
et aussi dans le cadre de la visite en
magasin on peut imaginer dans une grande
surface
un client qui décideraient d'enlever son
masque et continue magazine et ça
pourrait mettre le détail et dans une
position un peu délicate mais vous
l'avez dit aussi l'acceptabilité sociale
généralement est bonne pour le mascis au
québec françois vrai quoi plus de six
québécois sur dix sont en accord
facilement ouais donc le climat est bon
jusqu'à maintenant mais vous l'avez
évoqué la question des âmes en écoute et
on attend du saut tout à l'heure de la
conférence de presse de monsieur legault
entre 400 et 6000 dollars qui pourraient
être imposées aux commerçants commencent
est accueillie du côté de vauban mais
vous savez il ya deux éléments alias le
premier c'est la responsabilité qui
doivent qu'il doit pourquoi fond de
contrôle adéquats l'entrée du magasin
pourquoi il payerait pour un étudiant
qui pourrait être fautif
au lieu que le client lui-même paye pour
sa propre faute c'est un peu c'est un
peu un élément l'eau à accepter les
détaillants de notre côté aussi
mais c'est ses couleurs
actuels vont se rajouter à de nombreux
coups depuis le début de la réouverture
des magasins
donc ça commence à peser lourd sur les
commerçants qui en ont quand même
beaucoup encore à faire pour réussir par
exemple devoir embaucher quoi du
personnel supplémentaire
j'apprécie aussi vous le détailler les
coûts pour les commerçants lorsqu'on a
annoncé la réouverture ça coûte et
convient à peu près là mais ça dépend
vraiment du thil de commerce de genre de
surface aussi la moyenne a semé mais on
peut calculer facilement qu'à 5/10 même
jusqu'à dix mille dollars par magasin ça
peut même aller au delà des épiceries
qui ont mis vraiment les des stations de
lavage de mains qui ont coûté quand même
thl donc on a un pop turrel à l'entrée
ou d'un pote désinfectant d'engraisser
c'est une chose mais encore là souvent
il ya des besoins de personnel pour
contrôler les gens dans tree hill tout
l'affichage en magasin qui est installé
leurs charges planches et souvent
bondées masque à fournir aux employés
une visière l'ipec six glaces et cetera
fait que ça manque quand même des coûts
importants la peau des les commerçants
qui ont été aussi fermé pendant une
période d'un mois jusqu'à trois mois et
qui doivent encore assumer les frais de
ces fermetures et on doit prévoir donc
l' embauche de personnel supplémentaire
également mais probablement que ça va
venir avec ses effectivement pour
s'assurer de bien contrôler cette
nouvelle règle cuillé de sa jupe est ce
qu'est un risque pour le chiffre
d'affaires des commerçants de voir des
gens qui refusent de porter le masque
même si généralement une acceptabilité
sociale et qui évite de plus en plus les
commerces
écoutez on est dans un contexte où dans
la reprise est là l'ouverture des
commerces chaque client est important
détaillant présente de façon générale
qui fait son chiffre de son plein le
chiffre d'affaires pour certains
secteurs de commerce
donc les clients sont tous importants
devant main sur ce que les dts assauts
de bien ni recevoir de faire une
expérience très positive malgré les
contenus concrets taxe fera donc d'avoir
refusé des clients bien entendu ça fait
mal au coeur ce serait dommage que les
tiens est là
enfin on a perdu le message du premier
ministre qui vraiment encourager les
citoyens à agir de façon responsable
on sait que la grande majorité m'ont le
faire comme ils l'ont fait depuis le
début d'un respect des règles avec les
commerçants et on espère que ça ne
devrait pas sacré au pâtis situation
problématique justement à ce niveau là
est généralement le sud ouest que les
clients sont venus sont compare donc
l'achalandage actuellement à une année 2
en sédiments parakois par rapport à
période comparable si j'exclus de
certains secteurs comme tout ce qui
touche le plein air la cour de la maison
les piscines extérieures qui sont
vraiment en progression fulgurante par
rapport aux années précédentes sont pas
la moyenne des détaillants ont peu parlé
d'environ 50 et 70 pour cent de
l'achalandage qui sont revenus dans les
magasins de 50 à 110 % le volume
d'affaires ça représente quoi
mais dans le contexte où les peler les
gens vont sont plus disciplinaire noah
choses devront mieux vaut moins pour
magasiner pour plus pour faire des
achats dans le pense que c'est un
challenge achalandage l'eau se
transforme beaucoup plus un air chaud et
on pourrait dire que pour quelqu'un que
60% d'achalandage faut peut-être avoir
60 % 4 mai pour cent de son os de son
volume d'affaires à peu près ce qu'on
peut dire de façon générale donc et
encore un chemin à faire pour récupérer
l'ensemble de son chiffre d'affaires et
d'assumer les coûts d'opération donc les
gens lorsqu'ils se présentent en
commerce on achète navale davantage on
pourrait dire même si vous avez suivi le
magazine en sachant que vous allez avoir
faire peut-être un peu la file vous avez
avoir des contacts de magasinage niveau
du respect des règles et tous les gens
ont appris davantage effectivement j'ai
vraiment pour des achats et un peu moins
pour dix neuf vitrines de magasinage
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur droit
alors on souhaite bonne chance à vos
membres puis on a la pression
effectivement comme on disait au début
pour les commerçants c'est encore une
nouvelle mesure qu'on leur impose
ouais et puis on invite les citoyens à
respecter les délais les demandes
grandes mains mais aussi à continuer
d'encourager les détaillants au québec
que ce soit dans la localité où les
bannières québécoise les autres des
terrains qui sont basées au québec elles
existent importante pour la survie de
notre économie mais aussi encourager des
détails incarnons comme vous avez des
bulles
beaucoup sur les épaules message est
passé merci beaucoup monsieur droit
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous